it seems that Emperor Palpatine owes his
epic Star Wars return to another guy
said sir that's according to a new
interview with Colin Trevorrow in Empire
the magazine not the pangalactic evil
organization during this interview
Trevorrow who was a 1-point attached to
write and direct the 9th film in the
skywalker saga revealed that it was JJ
Abrams who decided to bring back the
iconic character
[Music]
Javaris remarks to empire focused on his
time working on Star Wars a rise of
Skywalker which he and his writing
partner Derek Connelly departed in
September 2017 the director who was best
known as the driving creative force
behind the Jurassic world franchise told
the magazine that the return of the
notorious s Lord was the story element
that finally helped the rest of the
film's plot fall into place
he explained bringing back the Emperor
was an idea JJ brought to the table when
he came on board it's honestly something
I never considered I commend him for it
this was a tough story to unlock and he
found the key to Varro spent enough time
working on the rise of Skywalker to
score a story credits but he wasn't
willing to go into detail when asked
about two specific contributions to the
script
he told Empire that's not my place
especially right now I know how hard
this crew has worked over the past two
years a lot of them are working with us
now on the next Jurassic world movie I
want to support them as they put this
film out into the world in the end I'm
just proud to have my name in space he
did however give credit to Abrams for
keeping what worked and jettisoning what
didn't in regard to the rise of
skywalker story Javad Rob explained I'm
not sure anyone who chooses a creative
life should expect things but I'm
grateful to JJ for embracing some of our
ideas it's exciting that fans will get
to see the moments I've felt essential
to all of us
Abrams of course co-wrote and directed
2015's a force awakens and in a recent
conversation with Uproxx
the director revealed that the seeds for
emperor palpatine eventual return had
been planted all the way back when that
film was still in the scripting stage
Abrams said when you look at this as
nine chapters of a story perhaps the
weirdest thing would be if Palpatine
didn't return
strangely his absence entirely from the
third trilogy would be conspicuous when
co-writer Lawrence Caston and I worked
on the force awakens we didn't do it in
a vacuum we very purposefully looked at
what came before to ask
where does this feel like it's going
fortunately the last Jedi director when
Johnson didn't step on Abraham's toes in
crafting that film story
Abrams remembered when Ryan was brought
son we met and we taught about things
and he wrote his story and when I read
the script I realized this didn't get in
the way of anything casted and I talked
about as it turns out that particular
stroke of luck has been significant to
the production of the last Jedi's
upcoming sequel Abrams continued there
was some very specific things we did get
to do invites of Skywalker that we were
laughing and going oh my god we're
finally doing that thing we talked about
five years ago
of course Palpatine's role in the movie
is still a total mystery so nobody can
be sure exactly what Abrams and Caston
talked about a half decade ago that will
finally come to fruition that the
Emperor survived being tossed into a
seemingly bottomless abyss by Anakin
Skywalker at the conclusion of Return of
the Jedi or was he resurrected through
some arcane means possibly by harnessing
the mysterious power of the dark side of
the force above all else what on earth
could as masterplan possibly be and how
does it involve the burgeoning Jedi Rey
and kylo Ren heir apparents of the
Empire's legacy only time will tell
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]